حمل الرئيس الروسي واولادي مير بوتين حمله
اوكرانيا مسؤوليه نشوب الحرب وقال انه لم
تتح اي فرص لتسويه الازمه واضاف بوتين ان
خطر الحرب النوويه اخذ في التصاعد لكنه
اكد في اجتماع مع اعضاء مجلس حقوق الانسان
في روسيا ان الاستراتيجيه النوويه الروسيه
تعمل على مبدا الرد وان بلاده تنظر الى
اسلحه الدمار الشامل باعتبار انها اسلحه
دفاعيه
ستايل
اول من يستخدم سلاح النووي تحت اي ظرف
واذا لم تكن روسيا البادئه باستخدام
السلاح النووي فانها لم تكون الثانيه ايضا
لان امكانيات استخدام هذا السلاح في حال
توجيه ضربه نوويه لا اراضينا محدوده
للغايه
استراتيجيهتنا المتعلقه باستخدام وسائل
الدفاع هي للرد على ضربه خاصه اننا ننظر
الى اسلحه الدمار الشامل كاسلحه الدفاع
الاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه موجوده بكثره
في اوروبا ونحن لم ولن نقدم اسلحتنا
النوويه الى اي احد لكننا سنحمي حلفاءنا
اذا لزم الامر